bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 2 février
en dix ans la criminalité en france
augmenté de 2 % le nombre de délits
recensés en 99 et quasiment stable par
rapport à l'année précédente nous vous
proposerons de reportage l'un dans un
sens tous les éducateurs sont des
militaires et les stagiaires des
délinquants et puis l'exemple d'un
service de prise en charge des victimes
de la violence à montpellier rien ne
paraît pouvoir empêcher en autriche la
formation d'un gouvernement conservateur
extrême droite le président les chiens
doit se prononcer demain surprise aux
états unis avec la victoire de john
mccain dans la primaire côté républicain
face au favori george bush junior
conduire et téléphoner peut entraîner
des accidents mortels à antibes ce fut
le cas il ya quatre jours la répression
contre les porteurs s'organise
et puis la facture du passage à l'an
2000 à londres est lourde le dôme du
millénium déjà contesté est quasiment
délaissé par les anglais un peu plus de
trois millions cinq cent mille crimes et
délits recensés par la police et la
gendarmerie de l'année dernière 7
environ 2 % de plus qu'il ya dix ans
certes il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
précaution ces chiffres de délinquance
et de criminalité souvent mis en doute y
compris au sein de la police on notera
quand même que d'une année à l'autre
entre 98 et 99
la délinquance est resté stable ou
presque que l'île de france concentre
plus du quart de celle ci pour toute la
métropole que c'est la région poitou
charentes qui a connu la hausse la plus
importante est que c'est en haute
normandie que la baisse des délits est
la plus forte toujours pour 99 il faut
évidemment rapporter tous ces chiffres
aux populations concernées détails
maintenant avec pascal douce est bon et
bernard onf l'est
à chacun ses cérémonies celle de la
police et de la gendarmerie française
anime toujours le début de l'hiver
depuis 1969 date à laquelle furent
publiées les premières statistiques des
crimes et délits
autrement dit les chiffres de la
délinquance on apprend cette année que
celle ci ne progressent que de 0,1 0,7
pour cent par rapport à 81 18
puis l'on peut aller dans le détail et
constaté la baisse de la délinquance des
mineurs après trois années de hausse
consécutive
ou encore déploré une forte progression
des agressions ou vol avec violence
l'ennui c'est qu'au fil des ans
journaliste et scientifique ont pris
l'habitude de n'accorder qu'une
importance relative à ces statistiques
passons sur les accusations de truquage
de chaque camp politique au gré des
alternances l'essentiel est ailleurs
beaucoup reprochent aux chiffres
officiels de ne pas refléter la réalité
mais uniquement l'activité de la police
dans tous les pays développés aux
états-unis en grande-bretagne dans
beaucoup de pays de l'union européenne
on croise un certain nombre de données
de provenances diverses on peut promener
croiser les données qui proviennent des
assurances celles qui proviennent du
monde médical
celles qui proviennent des sociétés de
sécurité privées celles qui proviennent
également de l'état et ainsi avoir une
vision réaliste mais la vision de l'état
français est traditionnellement une
vision un peu arrogante voilà on vous
dit que c'est comme ça c'est comme sa
voisine en octobre dernier l'état fait
un premier pas en cherchant à traquer le
chiffre noir de la délinquance
autrement dit le nombre de faits subis
par des victimes qui pour toutes sortes
de raisons n'ont pas porté plainte
on appelle cela une enquête de
victimation
et le résultat est spectaculaire en
matière de vols dans les voitures par
exemple 50% des victimes ne portent pas
plainte
chiffre à peine moins élevé pour les
vols à la tire la question est
maintenant de savoir si le pouvoir
politique quel qu'il soit est capable de
supporter une telle réalité statistique
réalité ou amplification médiatique
permis ces statistiques de délinquance
il est donc celle qui concerne les
mineurs dans les zones urbaines dans ou
autour des établissements scolaires la
violence commise par des jeunes de moins
de 18 ans fait pourtant l'homme
est d'autant de prévention que de
répression depuis 1986 une association a
été créée avec pour objectif d'aider des
jeunes délinquants pour leur réinsertion
sociale et professionnelle et quand je
dis jeunes délinquants ce sont autant de
condamnés que deux mineurs en détention
provisoire
400 organise des stages diderot
socialisation agnès garder diane
richards se sont rendus en haute-loire
la soupe cher dans un camp rattaché à la
maison d'arrêt du puy où l'on accueille
des mineurs de 16 à 18 ans selon des
principes très militaire 6h30 debout ça
ne leur est jamais arrivé ici pas de
grasse matinée mais lit au carré
treillis et rangers comme à l'armée
nous sommes au centre de la souchère en
haute loire 14 délinquants
multirécidivistes ont été placés dans ce
centre de réadaptation sur décision de
juge pour enfants le matin on se lève on
s'est engueulés dessus juge pas
l'encadrement 5 militaire volontaire
détaché le temps du stage vous allez
directement effectué à argentan relatif
une fois plus
concert pied et pompe dans la neige
c'est ce qu'on appelle ici le réveil
musculaire
ce matin là ici ou 1 10 degrés les
couleurs envoyée si c'est vrai on est en
plein air mais on n'a pas les barreaux
aux fenêtres
marien mais la nuit nous enferme quand
même on est quand même enfermé la mi mai
je vous dis que la queue y en a certains
gens qui pensent que la prison c'est dur
mais c'est une fois connu ses bastions
vient de passer un mois et demi en
détention pour vol et violences il n'a
pas encore été jugé trois mois de stage
la dernière chance pour éviter le
vautour reprises aux trois mois pendant
lesquels il vaut tout réapprendre
vous mettez quelques chiffres là les
deux voilà et après le droit et le
centre a et 1,2 ou t2 de de vous enlever
de force de combien de deux moins de 2
euros
voilà à l'atelier c'est un civil qui
tentent de leur apprendre les rudiments
d'un métier avec sa manière à lui de
leur tenir la main et de les aider à
oublier le passé
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est pas mon
problème on essaye de regarder devant un
ensemble
c'est la première chose que j'arrive
dans les airs il cassé les rétroviseurs
un adolescent sur trois ne récidive plus
à la sortie du stage sébastien aimerait
être pour cela ils s'imaginent père de
famille avec un travail pour une vie à
nouveau normal alors après cet aspect
concernant les auteurs d'actes de
violence nous avons choisi d'évoquer les
victimes chaque jour les médecins des
urgences reçoivent des enfants des
femmes des hommes qui ont subi des
sévices des viols des agressions il en
faut pendre les prendre en charge sur le
plan thématique c'est à dire les
blessures du corps et sur le plan
psychologique
karine comme annecy pascal points sont
partagés un peu du temps d'un service
dit de victimologie c'est à l'hôpital
lapeyronie à montpellier
cette jeune fille a été amené aux
urgences pour des coups sur la face
externe et 2 avant moi donc à s'était
protégé de gym ballet ans du coup de
balai donnés par son papa
comme chaque lundi les responsables des
différents services de l'hôpital se
réunissent autour de la même table et du
même thème la violence
ce matin la réunion est consacrée aux
enfants urgences pédiatrie chirurgie
pédopsychiatrie chacun bien ici au
service médecine légale munis des
dossiers qui mérite une vigilance
particulière est venu aux mains avec des
lésions eric matheuse du front des
ecchymoses hémorragie secondes ivan et
une morsure de la joue cette année du 10
expliqué par une chute de 10 on a fait
un signalement au procureur pour pour
cet enfant pour proposer une mesure de
protection c'est dans les entrailles de
l'hôpital à deux étages sous terre qu'a
été créée il ya un an cette unité de
victimologie entre chambre mortuaire
celle de tout si les médecins légistes
accueille aussi ceux qui ont survécu à
la violence
lorsque quelqu'un est violée qu'ils
soient morts où qu ils soient vivants il
ya un expert qui va l'examiner donc on
se crée une expérience une pratique
d'examen de ce genre de victimes il est
bien évident qu étant médecin examinant
des victimes plusieurs centaines par an
il ya un moment on se dit que le
certificat médical est insuffisante il
faut passer à autre chose il n'attrape
pas le bras et mon égard sache en effet
des habits tout de suite à gauche et il
a commencé à me parler comme 10 ans dès
que ça s'est fait en famille
je manquais plainte ce qui va en avocats
voulaient deposit dossier il faudrait
par mois tient jusqu'au bout vous eu
toujours dans l'hôtel taj aurais je la
ville est déserte trop grande pour
pouvoir me cachais d'être quelqu'un la
race tour comme il me faisait envie
c'est pareil dit jean port joli prince
au qui va arriver
ils ont pris plaisir à vous taper une
insomnie principal plaisir enfin on
la faute à personne c'est une chance
extraordinaire ce que vous voulez
donc faites ce que vous voulez mais on
est là dans les bons temps de
s'apercevoir que la violence est pas
uniquement un bleu que l'on doit soigner
une plaie que l'on doit ce futur et
c'est autre chose c'est le
retentissement psychologique la
prévention vaut ce retentissement c'est
la prise en charge médico judiciaire
l'indemnisation des victimes
la sanction des coupables je crois que
les gens deviennent plus tolérants à la
violence ne tolère plus cette violence
subie et donc ils veulent ce qui me
semble normal qu'on après une nuit en
chambre en un an 800 victimes de
violence surtout des femmes et des
enfants ont été reçus dans ce service
dans ces réunions le secret de ces
consultations l'hôpital brise la loi du
silence
j'ajoute que peu avant midi à lille
hellemmes deux jeunes ont agressé un
chauffeur de bus ils ont frappé au
visage
en signe de protestation aussitôt tous
les conducteurs du réseau de transport
lillois se sont arrêtés de travailler
plus aucun bus ne devrait circuler avant
demain matin à lille comme c'était
probable et prévisible dès hier soir en
autriche le parti conservateur et parti
libéral d'extrême droite de jörg haider
se sont mis d'accord sur un programme
mais sur la composition d'un futur
gouvernement ni lady mille manifestants
rassemblés en fin d'après midi à vienne
contre cette coalition ni les états
d'âme du président de la république
autrichienne tôt masquer les styles n'y
pourront rien changer sans doute demain
cette coalition gouvernementale sera
officiellement avalisée avec juste un
détail la signature d'une déclaration
sur les valeurs démocratiques à vienne
pour france 2 patrice ramdane et gilles
jacquet une vraie pagaille de celle qu
affectionnent leur kaiser quand il est
au centre de la mêlée
avec son allié conservateur il
s'engouffre dans le palais présidentiel
pour y présenter son projet de
gouvernement qu'en sait-on pas grand
chose sinon que l'extrême droite
revendique la vie chantal rich et cinq
ministères justice défense finance
affaires sociales et équipements à
proximité on s'invective hitler est
arrivé au pouvoir démocratiquement sans
porte un jeune homme calme toi lui
répond la dame en lui rit entre les
riders jamais un homme a sorti sa
pancarte
un policier lui colle un pv motifs s'est
pas encore l'heure de manifester
anecdotique
sans doute mais révélateur d'un état
d'esprit le règlement c'est le règlement
le verdict des urnes c'est le verdict
des urnes voilà pourquoi et d'heures
attend tranquillement son heure
d'autoriser le pays paralysé depuis
quatre mois
le gouvernement n'a pas pu prendre une
seule décision depuis quatre mois et la
simple il ya un gouvernement qui est
prêt à travailler là dessus
haider quitte le palais hilare il y
reviendra demain en fin de matinée avec
sous sol pour recueillir les
commentaires du président sur leur
programme
en attendant que peut-il se passer ceux
ci une manifestation des étrangers des
autrichiens beaucoup d'intellectuels
dans le cortège un mot d'ordre halte
haider et cette impression confuse
qu'ils commencent peut-être à se passer
quelque chose à vienne
tout cela sous les fenêtres du président
autrichien qui sans doute s'en félicite
cents manifestants hier plusieurs
milliers ce soir et demain combien c'est
sans doute la question que se posent
maintenant la pression sera pour vous
ailleurs
l'organiseur n'a pas hésité à comparer à
une excitation dans le poulailler le
projet de l'union européenne d'isoler
son pays c'est l'une de ses dernières
expressions colorées mais il en a eu
d'autres par le passé beaucoup plus
inquiétante puisqu'elle faisait montre
de ses sympathies consciente ou non
puisque à chaque fois il s'est excusé
pour le passé nazi rappel de ces petites
phrases brune de jörg haider avec jérôme
baugnies derrière l'image séduisante de
skieurs bronzé que se plaît à donner
york rider il y a un projet politique
xénophobe des affiches dénonçant
l'invasion étrangère et une fascination
pour le national socialisme c'est en 70
que commence l'ascension de ce fils d'un
couple de militants nazis du plaideur à
20 ans il fait rapidement son chemin
jusqu'à la tête du parti libéral
autrichien qui compte de nombreux
nostalgiques de l'époque où l'autriche
sous hitler faisait partie de
l'allemagne la nation autrichienne a été
une fausse couche idéologique du skipper
jeune gouverneur de la province de
carinthie à la frontière slovène
il connaît bien l'autriche profonde il
sait qu'il n'ya pas eu dans son pays
le même travail de dénazification qu'en
allemagne
en 91 il fait l'éloge de la politique de
plein emploi du troisième reich ce qui
lui coûte son poste de gouverneur
l'année suivante il est en campagne pour
les législatives
flattant chez ses électeurs la peur de
l'immigration venus de l'est
cela ne me dérange pas qu'on dise que je
suis contre les étrangers
les autrichiens savent parfaitement que
je suis un bon citoyen qui veut les
protéger des dangers qui les guettent
lors d'un débat au parlement il fait ce
qui est sans doute un lapsus révélateur
en parlant des camps de correction du
national socialisme au lieu de camp de
concentration puis il est enregistré sur
une caméra d'amateurs en train de faire
l'éloge d'une assemblée d'anciens ss
parmi vous je ne vois que des hommes de
caractère rester fidèles à leurs
convictions
même quand souffle des vents contraires
les 27% de son parti aux législatives
d'octobre dernier lui ouvre la route du
pouvoir il réussit à faire passer
l'image d'un homme moderne et
provocateur qui contraste avec une
classe politique trop sclérosé
mais quand il se livre à l'exercice
obligé des excuses publiques auprès des
familles de victimes du nazisme
il est visiblement moins à l'aise que
lorsqu'il prononce les mots qui blessent
il devant l'ambassade d'autriche à paris
à l'initiative du mrap mai en présence
d'élus politiques dont robert hue et
jack lang notamment une manifestation a
eu lieu en fin d'après midi pour
dénoncer le pas de la honte franchi à
vienne de son côté bruno mégret annonce
une contre manifestation sur le même
lieu
l'union européenne et au sein de celle
ci la belgique la france le portugal
semble en tête
l'union européenne a dès le début de
l'annnonce de cette possibilité de la
présence de l'extrême droite dans le
gouvernement autrichien était
particulièrement ferme le président
autrichien aurait donné son accord au
président jacques chirac pour que les
mesures d'isolement de l'autriche soit
rendue publique afin d'empêcher in
extremis la formation d'un gouvernement
avec l'extrême droite seule la hongrie
et la russie se refuse pour l'instant à
se joindre à d'éventuelles sanctions
tandis qu'israël a rappelé son
ambassadeur à vienne pour consultations
l'explication avec bernard le moins
c'est sans conteste en israël que les
réactions étaient les plus vives à
l'accord politique autrichien haider et
votre monde dit la banderole où celle ci
qui rappelle les millions de victimes de
l'inceste
la manifestation se déroule devant
l'ambassade d'autriche ou de députés
opposés pour une fois réunies l'un du
parti travailliste l'autre du likoud ont
déposé une pétition israël menace de
rappeler son ambassadeur
c'est un jour sombre pour l'autriche
un jour sombre pour l'europe un jour
sombre pour l'humanité qu'une personne
est un parti comme celui daider puisse
intégrer ce gouvernement autrichien
merci mme à bruxelles au coeur des
institutions communautaires le débat
particulièrement divisée l'ale droite du
parlement
certains sont allés jusqu'à demander la
mise en congé 17 eurodéputés autrichien
président en exercice de l'union
européenne le portugal a réagi par un
communiqué prudent dodgers en paille ou
un événement sérieux qui doit être
traité avec beaucoup de patience mais
aussi détermination une situation
complètement nouvelle et difficile
un signal qui doit être médité à berlin
le chancelier gerhard schröder a pris
acte de la déclaration des 14
réunis hier à bruxelles cela veut dire
que personne du gouvernement de vienne
sera reçu à berlin
et cela est important ni à paris ni à
madrid ni à lisbonne graves voire en
autriche arrivé au pouvoir une force
politique anti européenne et nos folles
et qui entretient une relation douteuses
avec le passé nazi et bien une telle
force dans mon point de vue va bloquer
l'europe à rome le premier ministre
massimo d'alema parle clairement de
crises et affirme que l'europe a le
devoir de singer cet après midi en
belgique
romano prodi et lionel jospin se sont
retrouvés à l'université de louvain ou à
la tribune le premier ministre français
a renouvelé son appel à la vigilance
particulièrement en ces jours où nous
refusons que l'extrême droite se voit
offrir un accès au pouvoir dans l'un de
nos pays membres à vienne où il réside
simon wiesenthal qui pendant toute sa
vie à traquer les nazis a refusé de
qualifier jorg haider de neo ou
promesses sa définition je cite haider
est un populiste de droite
reste qu'il divise leur aux états unis
dans la phase éliminatoire côté
républicains comme démocrates en
perspective de l'élection présidentielle
de novembre prochain la consultation
organisée dans l'état du new hampshire a
sérieusement modifié la donne chez les
démocrates al gore est talonné par bill
bradley mais chez les républicains le
grand favori george bush junior a et
électoralement corrigé par l'ancien du
vietnam john mccain washington
correspondance détiennent leenhardt avec
aaron game
voici donc celui par qui la surprise est
tarifé à 63 ans le sénateur républicain
de l'arizona a remporté cette première
élection primaire avec une avance
considérable plus de 15 points sur son
adversaire direct george bush junior
hier soir les militants jubilé et john
mccain lui se sentait pousser des ailes
mes chers amis l'élection primaire du
new hampshire se termine mais une grande
croisade nationale vient juste de
commencer
bardé d'un discours plutôt modérée pour
un conservateur il s'est concentré
depuis des mois sur ce petit état d'un
million d'habitants jouant la proximité
contre l'argent et les lobbys et faisant
valoir ses états de service militaire
john mccain est un authentique héros de
la guerre du vietnam où il resta
prisonnier pendant cinq longues années
avant d'entrer en politique je crois
qu'il va amener à ce pays ce qui va
manquer depuis trop longtemps
c'est un homme fort un candidat crédible
il occupera un jour la maison blanche
incontestablement c'est un coup de froid
pour george bush junior le fils de
l'ancien président américain
il reste toutefois le favori logique de
son camp il a le soutien du parti est un
trésor de campagne de 450 millions de
francs qui au final peut faire la
différence dans les autres états la
campagne va se jouer à la télé à coup de
spots publicitaires et à ce jeu là
quelqu'un comme georges bush et
favoriser parce qu'il a plus d'argent
que tout le monde grâce à sa victoire
hier soir mccain a définitivement gagné
ses galons de candidat crédible et la
prochaine primaire républicaine dans
quinze jours dans l'état de caroline du
sud promet d'être animée
il vient de se faire un plaisir de
bradouchka référence vietnam au fils de
l'ancien président américain
mais la première du new hampshire
n'était que la première étape d'un long
très long marathon électoral
le téléphone portable est sans doute un
progrès mais il est aussi un danger
la répression va donc s'accentuer sur
les automobilistes qui utilisent leur
téléphone portable en roulant car trop
d'accidents sont dus à cette pratique il
y a quatre jours sur la côte d'azur
une conductrice téléphone en main a
perdu le contrôle de son véhicule
et puis heurté une autre voiture dans
laquelle se trouvait une femme enceinte
cette dernière a perdu son enfant
la conductrice auteurs d'accidents a été
écroué récit olivier théron et fabrice 6
rue ly 1500 contraventions en 99 dans
les alpes-maritimes près de 25000 à
paris le code de la route ne veut pas de
téléphone au volant
la contravention et de deuxième classe
230 francs 140
si on paie tout de suite dans certains
départements à la demande des procureurs
elle peut aller jusqu'à 1000 francs il
faut marquer les esprits faire prendre
conscience du danger
je sais qu'on dit que ces générateurs
d'accident c'est pas correct que ce soit
vos bonnes
il ya quatre jours il ya une dame qu'à
perdre qui était enceinte de huit mois
qui a perdu son enfant parce qu'une
autre dame qui était en train de
téléphoner de lui rentrer dedans
par exemple et la gendarmerie
effectivement perçoit ce cette
infraction comme une infraction grave
génératrices d'accidents au même titre
que les infractions en matière
d'alcoolémie en matière de vitesse pour
la sécurité routière et l'institut de
recherche sur les transports la voiture
et le téléphone se télescopent les deux
font appel ou même ressource à la même
attention
du coup les temps de réaction augmente
et le danger aussi les fabricants de
téléphones mobiles en mise au point des
kits dix mains libres de plus en plus
perfectionnés pour l'heure les
utilisateurs n'ont pas été sanctionnés
mais ça ne devrait pas durer ne
m'apparaît pas que là le kit mains
libres soient forcément là la solution à
tous nos problèmes
je crois qu'il faut quand même
considérer que la conduite est un art de
la vie de tous les jours qui réclame
beaucoup de concentration et beaucoup
d'attention le message est clair
mais il est encore loin d'être respectée
la ministre de la solidarité martine
aubry ouvre cet après midi une série de
rencontres avec les syndicats des
personnels hospitaliers infirmiers et
autres agents des hôpitaux publics
demain ils doivent manifester à paris en
province pour demander des moyens
supplémentaires pour l'hôpital et pas
seulement une négociation sur les 35
heures nous avons déjà évoqué dans cette
édition le rassemblement à paris de
spécialistes cancérologue venu faire le
point depuis le début de la semaine sur
les recherches et les avancées
thérapeutiques
demain ce sera un véritable sommet
mondial avait dit représentant 260
gouvernement qui se tiendra sur ce sujet
une charte sur même signé cela nettement
vendredi à l'elysée jean michel
carpentier et mathieu dreujou ont
recueilli le témoignage de l'institut
curie à paris d'une femme médecin en
charge d'un service spécialisé dans le
traitement de la douleur et de la
souffrance des malades
ceux ci attendent des médecins une
meilleure écoute
incessantes bataille contre le cancer
pour l'or qui cherche et cherche encore
le meilleur confort possible pour les
malades
la guérison semble tellement lointaine
on essaye d'être extrêmement moderne est
extrêmement pointues sur la technologie
pour arriver à le soigner du mieux
possible mais on essaye aussi de ne pas
traiter simplement un tueur mais traiter
le patient qui qui autour de la tumeur
par les écouter rassurer ça décrit pour
le médecin la lutte semaine à deux est
malade est une personne il ya une
exigence du patient qui est en train de
changer dans la façon effectivement dans
les patients sont capables de nous
interpeller de nous dire mais ne serait
ce que j'aime aller c'est pas normal
je pense qu'il y avait un temps
quelqu'un qui avait le cancer cities et
qu'il avait mal on avait tendance à lui
répondre c'est normal vous avez le
cancer il ya plein de de soucis comme ça
que les patients pour lequel ils nous
interpellent parfois on les entend
parfois on les entend pas mais s'ils ont
progressé aussi beaucoup parce que la
demande vient de l institut curie on
avoue ses limites
qui survivra qui succombera essence
souvent le médecin ne le sait pas cela
tient aux malades aux défis qu'il ose
lancer à sa propre souffrance l'adoption
ce matin en conseil des ministres d'un
projet de loi sur la solidarité et le
renouvellement urbain il vise à mieux
répartir les hlm et prévoit des
sanctions financières pour les communes
qui n'ont pas assez de logements sociaux
on en recenserait 1113 exactement sur 36
mid
il faut savoir qu'en dessous d'un
minimum de 20% du nombre des logements
qu'elles gèrent ces communes devront
payer une taxe de 1000 francs par
logement hlm manquants les exemples en
région parisienne ne sont pas rares en
voici un c'est à vincennes le reportage
de jean pellieux et jean louis goût sert
avec pour commencer l'histoire d'une
famille qui attend dans un hôtel face à
la gare 2009 saint georges
cet hôtel héberge depuis deux mois la
famille fofana
le couple et leurs six enfants
habitaient à vincennes dans un hôtel
meublé d'où ils ont été expulsés avec 15
autres familles une seule famille a
obtenu un logement social dans cette
ville d'un scène préfèrent payer ici une
note d'hôtel de 7000 francs par mois les
fofana versant le 3000 francs pour des
conditions de vie plus que médiocre tous
les jours on ne nous pas des tricks pour
moi c'est ici tous les jours aux
assiettes de loisel est ma télé soir à
les choses comme ça c'est fait
le jugement assez lent parce que dégage
7000 francs par mois puis c'est des
allocations familiales est aussi ça fait
2 mai des z'arts printemps fait une
assez laid depuis dix ans les fofana
renouvelle en vain leur demande de hlm à
vincennes pas de place répondons
vincennes est certes une commune qui a
peu de hlm 6% mais ayant construit ces
dernières années les logements que lui
demandait le préfet la ville ne verse
aucune pénalité
en revanche avec la nouvelle loi elle
paiera une taxe de 1000 francs par
logement manquant soit au total près de
3 millions une sanction injustifiée
pour le maire c'est une ville
extrêmement dense moins de deux
kilomètres carrés 44 mille habitants
donc c'est lui extrêmement serré il ya
assez peu de place le terrain est très
cher et donc construire des logements
sociaux un logement social de 60 m² ça
coûte 600 mille francs
six cent mille francs à la ville à la
ville par logement c'est les
construisant sociaux la mairie de
vincennes ne peut pas dire qu'elle n'a
pas de terrain il y a des terrains
puisqu'il y a des
des constructions et la mairie aurait dû
présenter ces terrains d acheter pour y
faire du logement social
la menace de sanction semble porter ses
fruits voici la future zone de
construction de vincennes il comptera
quatre cent cinquante logements dont
près d'un quart de logements sociaux en
seine saint denis aujourd'hui c'est un
villepinte ouverture de confort tacle
salon international de l'électroménager
ray comme d'habitude depuis plusieurs
décennies des simulations futuriste sur
l'aménagement de nos cuisines il paraît
que les appareils électroménagers
peuvent devenir intelligent et que grâce
à l'ordinateur à distance on pourra
bientôt quelle horreur faire la cuisine
explication il avait été avec roger
matures la cuisine de l'an 2000 les
femmes en rêvait depuis longtemps mais
elle ne la voyez sûrement pas comme ça
avec un écran d'ordinateur sur la porte
du frigo qui permet de consulter des
recettes puis de cliquer pour allumer le
four bientôt depuis son bureau via
internet
on pourra aussi programmé son chauffage
ou gérer le système de sécurité de sa
maison
c'est toujours le gaz que les français
préfèrent pour cuisiner mais aujourd'hui
la technologie rend la flamme
intelligente on peut programmer la durée
d'une cuisson et si le feu s'était
accidentellement il se rallument tout
seul
aussitôt intelligent toujours ce plan de
travail qui réunit friteuse grill
électrique sur pierre de lave plaque au
gaz et une hotte télescopique pratique
mais cher près de 20 mille francs pour
l'ensemble
tout change de formes et de couleurs et
le fer à repasser n'est plus
indispensable
cette table se gonfle en se remplissant
de vapeur et efface tous les plis puis
son réservoir se transforme en un super
détachant pour les seuls
décidément même en l'an 2000 on ne veut
pas que les femmes oublient leur cuisine
ce bip à la taille retenti en cas
d'incident à la maison ici il signale
une anomalie de fonctionnement du lave
vaisselle
cette année les professionnels ne seront
plus les seuls à découvrir toutes ces
couleurs le salon confortait ouvrira ses
portes au grand public le week-end
prochain pour les femmes et pour les
hommes du sport du rugby avec la
composition de l'équipe de france qui
affrontera le pays de galles pour la
première journée du tournoi des six
nations samedi prochain à cardiff ce
sera en direct évidemment sur france 2
le nouvel entraîneur de l'équipe de
france bernard laporte a fait son choix
un choix commenté par marc maisonneuve
une photo avec rien des premiers de la
classe l'équipe de france les meilleurs
choisi par le seul qui garde ses
lunettes pendant les matches bernard
laporte l'entraîneur
cette équipe là c'est celle de ses choix
sa stratégie la conquête sur les touches
et les mêlées avec le renforcement du
milieu de terrain autour du capitaine
fabien pelous de robustes garçons
richard dourthe et thomas lombard la
mêlée forte c'est l'autre décision avec
christian califano marc dal maso et
franck tournaire abdelatif benazzi sera
associé à ce qui devient une véritable
rampe de lancement pour les lignes
arrières pour les artistes
les ailiers christophe dominici emile
ntamack et thomas castaignède la
stratégie c'est très bien dans un salon
de thé mai à cardiff
les vice champions du monde les français
n'y vont pas que pour prendre le thé
voilà puis demain bernard laporte sera
en direct depuis cardiff dans ce journal
avec ton tennis la coupe davis modifie
son règlement intérieur chaque équipe
aura désormais la possibilité de changer
un ou deux joueurs de simple le dimanche
pour le dernier match sans avoir à
produire un certificat médical comme
c'était jusqu'à lors le cas depuis
quelques jours l'équipe de france est au
brésil propose préparer sa rencontre
tandis que l'équipe du brésil s'entraîne
avec à sa tête
gustavo kuerten ils sont rassemblés dans
la ville de cortone florianopolis où se
trouvent nos envoyés spéciaux cristal
version et maryse richard
florianopolis est d'abord une île
réputée pour ses plages et ses
spécialités de crevettes
mais c'est aussi le royaume de gustavo
kuerten depuis qu'il a gagné roland
garros en 1997
le brésilien est devenu aussi populaire
qu'un footballeur et au brésil c'est un
tour de force
aujourd'hui on a guga et c'est un
honneur pour notre ville et pour le
réseau tout entier
guga comme on l'appelle ici c'est
entretenir sa popularité
les nombreux reportages télévisés qui
lui sont consacrés sont de véritables
bandes annonces à chacune de ses sorties
la culture brésilienne aurait pu le
pousser vers un autre sport mais c'est
le coeur qui l'a amené au tennis j'ai
toujours aimé les jeux individuels bien
sur un court de tennis
peut-être un jour je préférais jouer à
autre chose aux cards aux dominos chez
lui le souvenir de son père ancien
joueur aujourd'hui décédé est
omniprésent pour rester près de sa
famille l'enfant chéri du pays
habitants jurent à florianopolis pour
aider son frère et tous ceux qui sont
handicapés
goog a fait construire une école
spécialisée l'homme est aimé et respecté
il ne manquerait plus qu'une victoire en
coupe davis ella l'admiration serait
totale
sobrement les brésiliens ont surnommé
florianopolis le paradis sur terre mais
sur cette terre battue là ils ont bien
l'intention de faire vivre l'enfer aux
joueurs français
il fait 30 degrés l'air est chargé à
plus de 90 % d'humidité et le public
brésilien est réputé pour être
franchement hostile vis-à-vis des
équipes adverses
il y un mois lors du passage à l'an 2000
en direct sur france 2 nous vous avions
fait vivre les festivités londonienne
entre autres les feux d'artifice les
illuminations la tamise la réception
solennelle avec la reine sous le dôme du
millénium et quelques ratés comme la
grande roue récalcitrant aujourd'hui
notre correspondant benoît duquesne qui
a gardé un fameux souvenir de ce
réveillon nous apporte que nous nous
rapporte que pour la grande rousse va
mieux mais pour le dôme da c'est un bide
tony blair en personne inaugurant la
grande roue de londres une image furtive
et pour cause la route ce soir là ne
tourna pas heureusement le même soir
tony blair toujours lui exulter sous le
dôme à l'inauguration de ce qu'il
appelait le plus grand spectacle de la
terre qui devait faire de londres la
capitale de la planète
excusez du peu un mois plus tard le dôme
attend toujours les vingt-cinq ou trente
mille visiteurs escomptés par jour
d'après tous les sondages ce qui
viennent sont satisfaits seul problème
ils ne sont pas nombreux
alors comme toujours dans ces cas-là en
angleterre on parle argent
la loterie nationale a déjà financé 4 17
milliard qu'a coûté ce coup ding les
gestionnaires éclat maintenant 600
millions de plus de quoi faire bondir
l'opposition
c'est peu de monnaie ont fait de
l'argent par les fenêtres on joue avec
l'argent de la loterie
beaucoup de gens seront scandalisé que
l'on met plus d'argent public dans ce
projet et c'est là que la roue s'est
mise en marche avec un mois de retard
peut être mais cette fois elle tourne le
prix est abordable les fonds privés et
l'a vu à 140 mètres de haut imprenable
sur londres et ses environs bref pour
une fois les anglais sont contents la
presse dithyrambique pour vaincus
d'avoir enfin à londres une attraction à
la hauteur si l'on peut dire de la tour
eiffel qui la plupart des personnes qui
ont visité le dôme lente apprécié mais
il aurait préféré que l'argent public
aille dans les hôpitaux dans l'éducation
en revanche il aime beaucoup la roue
même si le retard à l'ouverture lui a
fait une mauvaise publicité
donc la grande passion de l'année
puisque ici par temps clair on peut même
en principe à percevoir le dôme a prouvé
qu'elle fera pouvoir de la tamise
ce n'est donc même pas la gagner et
puisqu'on le prix de la roue on peut
aussi voir le dôme il s'avance puis
comme le grand fiasco de l'année
d'accord mais par temps clair nous
arrivons à la fin de cette émission je
vous répète deux informations nous avons
développé d'avoir les chiffres de la
délinquance qui ont été publiés la
criminalité et les délits ont augmenté
de 2% 10 ans en france le nombre de
délits recensés en 99 et ce pendant
quasiment stable par rapport à l'année
précédente nous s'il vaut prendre tous
ces chiffres avec beaucoup de précaution
et puis ce soir à vienne il y avait
quinze mille personnes pour protester
contre la probable annonce demain
officiel la présidence de la république
autrichienne de la nomination de la
coalition entre le parti conservateur et
le parti libéral d'extrême droite
coalition gouvernementale donc en
autriche la météo c'est avec isabelle
martinet dans quelques secondes et puis
après la kiné ça se discute présentée
par jean-luc delarue à zéro heure
cinquante votre vraie fluence duprat
pour le dernier journal suivi d'un 1h10
des mots de minuit
philippe lefait demain à 7h50 dans mes
quatre vérités gérard morin recevra
bernard thibault le secrétaire général
de la cgt et puis à 13h vous retrouverez
karl vsphere et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir merci
je